-Our next guest is a talented
actor you know from
"Flight of the Conchords"
and the "Jumanji" movies.
He stars
in the HBO Max series,
"Our Flag Means Death."
New episodes are available
to stream Thursdays.
Let's take a look.
-If it were real, why would she
have sold it to you?
Why not keep the map herself
and find the treasure herself?
-Oh, strong question.
Love that.
-Well, maybe she's just lazy.
I mean, she works
down at the docks
selling maps,
for God's sake.
-Best of luck to you, mate.
I'm taking a nap.
-Last I heard a ship only has
one captain.
And the captain
of this vessel says
"On your feet,
we're having a day."
once I've changed.
-Please welcome to the show,
Rhys Darby, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show, Rhys.
-[New Zealand accent] Thank you.
-I've been a fan of yours for
a very long time.
And this is, I mean,
it's just an ideal role.
This is a real pirate?
-It is.
-Stede Bonnet.
-Yes.
So he's on the fringe
of well-known pirates.
But this one,
it's a crazy story.
So he had a midlife crisis
and decided to go
and become a pirate.
Now he was an aristocrat.
He had everything.
He was a wealthy landowner.
And to make matters worse,
he left his wife and kids
in the middle of the night
and just took off.
-It must be very fun to tell the
story of an unknown
or lesser-known,
I should say, pirate
and have so much fun
with the comedy side of it.
-It is. It's, it's there's
a lot to tackle there,
because why would he do it?
-Yeah.
-And you know, he survived
for a certain amount of time
without giving too much away.
[ Laughter ]
-Still, I don't get the sense.
-All pirates die in the end.
-Yeah.
-But look, he actually
purchased the boat, you know.
And he paid his pirates a wage.
And he, he even took obviously
all his fancy clothes with him.
And he even built a library
on his boat.
It was ridiculous, so.
-You, you mentioned
that he bought a boat.
You took this very seriously.
You took a sailing lesson.
-Mm-hmm.
-In order to play
to bring some authenticity
to the pirate.
Did you? Was it helpful to take
a sailing lesson?
-Well, I got that wrong
because of course,
this chap had no idea
what he was doing.
And unfortunately, I did.
So I had to double act
once I got here.
Oh, so you made the mistake
of learning a thing
that then you had to pretend
you didn't know how to do?
-I was too qualified. Yes.
That was that was me
going I'll do those ropes.
Or actually, no, no,
I don't know how to do them.
[ Laughter ]
-This is ah, this
is very interesting casting.
A delightful casting.
In the show, we see
a younger version of Stede.
And your son was cast to play
a younger version of you.
And here he is with with Taika
there with blood on his face.
[ Audience "Aw's" ]
-And that's yeah,
that's little Theo.
-Yeah.
-This is was his
first acting role.
-Oh, gotcha.
And did he take to it?
Did he enjoy it?
-Oh, he took everything to it.
And honestly,
hats off to this guy
because he had to do
his own stunts as well.
The stunt person didn't turn up
or was sick it was --
-Really?
-It was some sort of COVID issue
or laziness.
Anyway, I'm not sure.
But he was told
he had to run into a tree
so he'd never acted before.
And also he had to vomit.
So he was fed cold soup by
Taika. He had to do that.
Run into a tree and then on the
on the boat, in the river,
he was just throwing stones
at, you know,
he was literally abused.
So it was it was
all part of the role.
But at the end of it, he said,
"Look, I'm not sure
whether I like this as a job,"
and I said, "But you're so
good," I say.
And he said, "Alright, well,
from now on, I'm offer only."
-Really?
-Yeah.
So after one job, I don't know
whether that's a record.
-When you knock it out
of the park on your first job,
you switch to offer only.
-Yeah.
-So much like Stede, as well,
you, you were in the military
in real life.
-I was. Yeah, yeah.
I mean,
I've been wearing uniform
since I was 12, actually.
-Gotcha.
I did this air training corps
thing,
which in New Zealand
is like a little Air Force thing
for kids once a week.
And then I switched over
to the, to the Army.
It was more fun toys
to play with there.
And, and then I joined the
regular force
at the age of 17
and did this cadet school
and then was a signals operator
for four years.
-Wow. So you were
active military
for four years
and were you someone?
Did you bring your sense
of humor to that job as well?
-I did, unfortunately.
Yeah.
-Not a place where it's meant to
thrive, yeah.
-They said I'm good for morale,
but if there's an actual war
about to happen, we're worried
you're gonna ruin things for us.
-Yeah.
-So they politely let me go,
in the end, they --
it's a funny story.
They actually the C --
the C.O. brought me
into his office and he said,
"How do you think
the career is going?"
And I said, "Pretty good, sir."
And he went, "Have a seat.
I've got a pamphlet for you."
And, and he gave me
this pamphlet.
It was for a local university.
-Really?
And I said,
"Oh, wow, university!"
He said,
"That's be good for you."
He said, "You know, with your
English skills
and you're a good computer--
communicator."
I can't even say the word.
He got that wrong.
But I said, "Well, will I have
time off to do university."
And he said, "Oh yeah,
I think we'll give you,
I think we'll give you
a lot of time off."
-So this is interesting
because I think historically
people think of the military
and maybe setting up a booth
at a university
handing out pamphlets.
But this was you were
so unique
that they sent you
the other way.
-I'm one of the only ones
that was sent the other way.
I think, that yeah.
Which yeah,
it was the right move.
-They de-cruited you.
-Yeah, yeah. Yeah, it was.
It was a soft let go.
But I did manage
to keep the jacket.
-You -- Oh, they
let you keep your jacket?
-Yeah. I wanted all the kit, but
they said, No, we need that."
But, um,
you can take the jacket.
-Well, I think if you have
the full kit.
You can pretend
like you're still in the Army.
But if you just have the jacket,
people know your foolin'.
-That's it. Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah.
But you -- signals operator.
So you learned Morse code?
-Yes.
And is this something?
Do you forget Morse code
once you stop using it?
-Over time.
-Yeah.
-Absolutely.
But I've sort of stuck with it.
-Okay.
-It's a handy thing to have.
-I mean, it comes so in handy.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I look honestly, we were
the last of the Morse coders.
It's not even trained anymore.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-Well, I mean,
I guess that makes sense.
I'm surprised that
you were even in the generation
where they were using it.
-Well, this was New Zealand.
-Oh.
-So you know, I mean,
they stopped doing
Morse code last year.
-[ Laughs ]
-You know, it was an intensive
course like three months,
just hearing all the dots
and dashes
and you're writing stuff down,
you know,
and then my big job was all
these codes would come through
and I'd decode them
and then hand it to the officer.
And, you know,
the battle would commence.
-Could you still could you
still understand
or even could you speak
Morse code?
-Uh, yes, I could, certainly.
-Could you say something
in Morse code now?
-Okay. Here we go.
[ Imitating Morse code ]
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
-That was great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What uh?
I mean, are you --
do you want to tell us
what you said or should we just
wait until somebody
can, you know?
-Well, be funny the way.
I was going to tell you
it was, uh...
-What was it?
-"I wish I was somewhere else."
But it wasn't that! It was
"Seth rocks." There you go.
-[ Laughs ] "Seth rocks."
-You guys, that's Rhys Darby.
New episode of "Our Flag
Means Death" are available to
stream Thursdays on HBO Max.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."